[Music]
let's go to elizabeth in greenville
south carolina what's up elizabeth
hi thanks so much for taking my call
thank you what's going on
well my husband started his very first
ministry job about 18 months ago and i'm
afraid he's going to get fired
and
oh
hey and i don't know how to help
i know i know it's not funny
but i'm laughing anyway how long have
you all been married
we've been married about seven years and
what did he do before he started working
for jesus
i'm assuming that is that kind of
ministry
yeah definitely jesus ministry nothing
else
you said well actually i was like oh man
i missed the boat on this one
well he was actually a former navy guy
so the last call was actually kind of
really pertinent to
our situation here former navy
and then was a professional graduate
student for a couple of years those are
the marrying and endings
i was one of those
we got through it we got through it and
now he's here in this job and um
it's been really tough
so why do you think he's going to get
fired
he um
he's a youth pastor and so
he's constantly fielding
um complaints
from parents about his
lack of organization and lack of admin
skills um
and then
recently he
heard from the head pastor that he
doesn't feel like he respects him
and
um
the pastor's wife was actually
volunteering with the youth group for a
while and she just
messaged the entire committee that my
husband reports to and says i'm i'm not
helping anymore um
and if you guys want to hear about my
experience working under
this youth pastor please let me know
um so it just seems like
what was your husband's response to that
they actually this is all like in real
time
so
they have a phone call about it later
today and she's a counselor so i
i trust her to be very you know
forthcoming and honest and mature about
the situation but oh elizabeth i know a
lot of really immature counselors oh man
but hopefully she's hopeful she's great
um have you have you talked to her
called her directly
because there's this messiness when
you're at a church
um that also has administrative hr stuff
because in like it would be way out of
bounds for my boss here where i work to
get mad at me and then my wife to call
him
um
it would also be weird for somebody who
doesn't work here to volunteer to help
to join the john doloni team
and then to write a report and be like
that was a disaster which it kind of is
that was a disaster and if you want
mike's i mean so the whole thing's a
mess um
but i think i'd reach out and talk to
her that's just side side thing are
y'all have any relationship at all
yeah we do we actually um
we have really great terms and i feel
like she she could definitely share
stuff with me and we kind of
she's a new um pastor's wife too like
they've only been married for um about a
year so we've both kind of been thrust
into these positions of okay our
husbands have weird jobs
and
we you know have relationships with
people in the congregation
and they complain about our husbands
and but you know we're trying to have
connections and community
um and it's really hard to kind of
differentiate uh it's a disaster it's an
absolute train wreck of a mess yes oh
yeah which is why
uh pastors and especially their spouses
end up some of the loneliest people on
the planet because they got nowhere to
go
you know what i mean they end up with
nowhere to go
uh yeah and it's it's brutal and the
hard part is like what
what normally happens is the spouses of
the current ministers become really
close
and then one day you say hey i found
something at our house or my husband
expressed this and i'm worried about it
and now
you're going to your friend with a
concern
but now it's just become an hr issue
yeah right and so the whole thing's a
mess it's just messy messy messy i
personally don't like that the pastor's
wife did like recon on your husband i
don't like that i wish it had been a
little more upfront
um it sounds anyway that's that's beside
the point so what does your husband say
about all this does he know he's got a
problem
yeah he's really been he's been working
on it um on his administrative stuff and
the thing is is that i'm i'm really good
at it
and i do marketing and public relations
so i'm
you know i'm very type a and very good
at getting the word out about
events and things like that i mean like
i could just like sleep before
with
you know with the communication style
um and so when i try to step in to help
him kind of and give him suggestions
it's it's usually well received but um
i don't know how to
stop myself from scrolling over
him and doing his job for him but at the
same time when he's receiving complaints
about
you know
parents don't know about this event or
we don't have enough people signed up to
go to
you know a fun activity out of town it's
usually because he hasn't
really done due diligence on making
connections with the parents and making
sure they all know what's going on so
can we back out for a second
how much of this is you're scared your
husband's gonna lose his job and how
much of this is you're super frustrated
that
like
like he's he's not doing basic tenants
of the job and it happens to be the
parts that you're really good at too
can i tell you where this is really
hitting home for me my wife is a
master teacher an incredible k-12
teacher she's just
like a she's just a stud
and
she came and visited my classroom once
when i was teaching high school and her
quote to me was i don't know what that
was but that's not teaching
and i was like what are you talking
about i'm incredible and she's like
that's actually incorrect you're not
credible
and so
it actually became a thing where she we
never talked about it because we did it
so differently and it drove her crazy
and it's that's what i'm hearing a
little bit in your voice your husband's
about to get fired that we can talk
about that but it also sounds like
you're losing respect for the guy that
you're married to because he can't do
basic things that you do really well is
that fair
wow um losing respect i
i
yeah i guess so it just kind of seems
like gosh why can't you just
get it together or you know why can't
you just
why can't you just piece these parts
together and how can you not see when
you
put the word out about something the day
before an event of course people aren't
going to show up absolutely
why is he choosing why is he choosing
that successful why is he choosing that
i have a couple of different working
theories um
would you like my thesis statement um my
guess is a he doesn't like this job
it's not what he thought it was going to
be
or b
um he's overwhelmed or c he's lazy
i think it's a mixture of b and c
and maybe a little bit of a thrown in
um
he might
what i've noticed is
the little details that really matter to
people especially to other people on
staff
he feels like he's above them
um oh he better recognize him he better
recognize
wow well like meeting deadlines for
things that
you know he just he thinks are small
potatoes in the grand scheme of things
um
are
he neglects and so i'm constantly like
you have to like this matters to someone
it might not matter to you but it
matters to someone and the fact that
you're
kind of digging your heels in and not
doing this um
it's not great and that you know causes
tension and the team is really small and
so when you it's like five or six people
it falls on somebody
yeah yeah so you know you know you know
what's heartbreaking here
two things number one
people i work with may have had a
similar conversation with me in the last
couple years and two
um
not from the beneath thing i i don't i
don't jive with that there's no job here
beneath any of us um
the big thing is i had this conversation
with my 10 year old or 11 year old
recently
my 11 year old
and this is like a this is a very
immature man this is a maturity issue
you know what i mean it's a choice issue
and here at where i work where you know
dave ramsey's the ceo you'll see dave
picking up trash in a parking lot
he got a debt we all got a deadline the
other day on some book stuff and he was
the first one done
and he had more to do than i did
and he has infinitely less time
available than i do
you know what i mean like so it's a
maturity issue and i know that's
frustrating for you as your wife
has this always been this way does he
does he treat you like this did he treat
his navy career like this surely not
you really don't have an opportunity to
act that way in the navy
commanding officer you've got
you've got people that you report to
you've got a very systematic
thing
you know working for you so the deal is
he can do it if he chooses and if he
chooses not to because it's beneath him
that's a character issue and he
shouldn't be a pastor
you know what i mean because he's
teaching young people that things are
beneath him
that there will come i mean i don't want
that type of character around young
people
i want a youth my dad after he quit
being a cop for a long time became a
youth pastor and dude he was the first
one there six in the morning and he
would get home at two a.m that next
night because he was cleaning up the bus
in the parking lot
that's the guy i want around my kids you
know what i mean
and i know this is hard because it's
your husband
that's why i ask you is there a respect
issue here
yeah i mean when i think about
even the way that
he treats stuff around the house you
know like
i've fought really hard not to be the
type of
woman who argues about how the
dishwasher is loaded here and there but
i told him
after he had this conversation with the
pastor where he said i feel like you
don't respect me i was like you know i
i kind of get that if you're
doing something you might not be doing
something directly to say i disrespected
you but you might not be doing something
that indicates
you know
exactly exactly not respectful so here's
here's a gift you can give him
and that is
by not kind of saying things a little
bit maybe-ish
you deserve to be respected
and you deserve to have your voice heard
in your home
and he
might he might take off
who knows hopefully not
he he might
start to get it
when you stand up and say
for 10 years or 15 years how long
however long we've been married seven
years
you've never emptied i mean you've never
done this dishwasher the right way and
i'm telling you this is somebody whose
wife did that for me and it ended up
being a gift
and when you say when i ask you to do
something like this around here and you
and you dismiss it
i feel disrespected i feel less than i
feel like you think you are more
valuable than me that's the story i tell
myself
and he needs to hear that because this
may be the first time he's heard some of
these things
and at some point i hate to tell you
this he's going to have to get fired or
have some sort of big awakening
before this type of character stuff
shifts because he's walking around the
world as though
um it all revolves around him
is that fair you're so yeah you're so
right i've never seen it like that
before but you're right
he probably complains about the way they
made his steak or his burger or his
whatever or they can't believe they
cleaned my car like this but everything
is a
through a lens of
how does it impact me not
as the heart of a minister should be and
the heart of a husband should be
how does this impact my wife and the
people that whose kids i'm taking care
of
right
most of the ministers i work with
have given so much of themselves to
everyone around them that they've got
nothing left for themselves this is the
inverse of that
i want my job
yeah yeah
it's really nice so here's what i think
you do i think you after the call today
hopefully he's still employed
my guess is um he will be but he'll have
some strict stuff
in this moment i think it's valuable if
y'all get out of your home and you go
somewhere and like i told the last
caller
and you tell him
this stuff that's being told to you is
right i feel it too as your wife
and i'm willing to walk alongside you as
you begin to as you change your lens you
change your glasses on how you're going
to begin to interact with the world
because we have to have a world of
service if you're a minister you can
have a world of service if you're a
husband you got service if you're a wife
you'll serve serve serve
and this thing's going to be done inside
out and in my life here's what that
means don't ever be late again never
because it's it's a it somebody else has
to pick that stuff up somebody else has
to have a conversation with somebody if
i'm late kelly's got to tell the caller
sorry we're running behind here she's
got to clean up my mess
james has to
i create ripple effects when i do that
or if i don't park in the right place or
if i don't get my money turned in or if
i don't fill in whatever it happens to
be
that'll get my emails turned in whatever
this is about dignity and respect and
you all need to sit down and have that
hard conversation and for what it's
worth he feels it on you elizabeth he
feels
you
looking at him looking down at him look
like almost disgust almost like what are
you doing what
it's good to get that stuff out
it's good to get that stuff out